jean-page is the duke of hastings in
bridgeton it's streaming now on netflix
and i mean this thing is a global
phenomenon 82 million households
if someone isn't a member of one of
those 82 million households uh tell us
what it's about uh it's the period drums
you know and love but not as you know
them it's faster wittier funnier sexier
considerably sexier um
very glamorous uh and just unashamed of
its own joy and so it's kind of we did
our best to kind of subvert the things
that you think you know about period
dramas and let you have a bit more fun
with them because we all need a bit of
fun at the moment and this comes from
that kind of incredible
shonda rhimes world shonda land which
you were in shonda world sunderland
already yes uh i've been working
for shonda for the last three years
before bridgeson in a show called for
the people i've been doing a new york
lawyer for doing my best kind of fast
talking high traffic type of acting um
and
shonda didn't actually know that i was
british when they were casting bridgeton
she was just like i want what he was
doing in that show but british and then
i turned up and we had our meetings
she's like wait you're you're not
american it's like no no this is
actually what i do you'll be the first
person to allow me to act in my own
accent for about six years um which was
lovely wow and i appreciate that very
much it was it was great not quite my
own accent i'm a little bit more
confident so where you actually are a
little bit down yeah but
i was a bit disappointed i was like i
mean
it's a lot of effort oh very good and of
course the two of you
who share a cast mate nichola yes
yes yes lovely nicholas yeah yeah and of
course that's why i started watching uh
bridgeton it's uh and you're one of the
reasons i stopped watching my best yeah
actually because i live alone and and
there's a pandemic going on and just
watching very beautiful people have a
lovely time dancing and having sex i'm
like you know i don't want to watch that
crying eating beans in my pants
another episode i hate myself
i'll just eat a radish open look
go back to the garden balco no
bridget's into the
radishes they would grow but now do you
you have a trick to get into it do you
yeah absolutely so when i was preparing
i didn't know a dairy accent first off
and then i thought who do i know and
then i thought oh nadine from girls
aloud is extremely dairy and then i
don't know if people will know this but
there was an extremely controversial
incident
in the early 90s in ireland so good it
was so good i feel like it was the first
irish sort of pop culture tv moment it
was pop stars the irish version which
only had about 50 entrants because we
don't have as big a population um so she
went on and lied about her age but she
got found out on camera stop it yeah
okay so she's gotten into the band and
then her on camera interview like the
first one to introduce yourself who you
are she said madam's nadine coyla from
lark hill and larry dana birth 15th 685
mecca me germany and then she thinks for
a second and goes what date of birth did
i say you know fifteenth of the second
oh and then it fades
and she's she's she's outed herself on
camera but everyone lost the plot
do the phone call to her mother do
everything mommy do the whole thing
daddy put my passport in the car mommy
will you look at my handbag for my
passport and it was all a lie she knew
she was 16 she was meant to be 18.
what is it about you lot pretending
you're different ages
because she wanted to make it through
that's but then but then she got and
girls allowed it actually worked out
much better you see yeah yeah and we
ended up with an amazing moment of her
sobbing in the back of a renault spas
being driven away
i
also did that whole thing in my audition
and it was very awkward because you did
it as a speech yeah but they didn't want
me to it's not like they said would you
mind doing your pre-preparedness
speech i just sort of started speaking
and they sort of were looking at me and
i thought well this could really go
either way you know it's all the
executives from channel 4 and the
director and the writer and i just
started doing it but i got the job it's
all fine
very good
golden rushville is back in bridgeton
season two it comes to netflix from the
25th of march and uh
yeah
queen charlotte she's a real fan
favorite and there's a lot more of her
in this season yes there is
she's back with a vengeance for her
naughtiness and joy
it's a really brave thing i think
they're doing because that first season
was as we said so successful but this
season there's a real pivot and they're
focusing on different characters
yeah well bridgeton is based on the
books by julia quinn and each book is on
um a sibling of the bridgeton family and
so our series basically is has it's an
ensemble but within that ensemble we
have different love stories in each
season which i don't think has ever been
done there's nothing kind of like that
out there
so this time around it's johnny bailey
and it's a love triangle
and uh yeah we kind of get to see him
blossom and grow into yeah the man that
he becomes
and do we get to
see him i mean is it as raunchy as the
first season
um it's bridgeton
so um and it's about love
um and the kind of escapades that people
get up to about so yes so yeah i think
i'm thinking yes yeah yes and obviously
this comes from the great uh american
showrunner shonda rhimes shondaland and
one of the things i think people love
about the show is the colorblind casting
was that one of the things that could
have appealed to you about it that you
know seeing london being that diverse
yeah i think definitely you know you
want as actors to be in something that
really represents the world that we're
living in at the moment and i think
that's really really important
yeah i'm very proud very proud that
we're representing
we have diverse diversity and we're
reflecting the world that we're living
in and i think i've read a thing you
said in an interview i really liked that
you said normally when you get a part
you're kind of leaning into your dad and
this is the first time you're leaning
into your mom yeah absolutely i mean you
know i've played the kind of
stereotypical black characters nothing
wrong with that very proud to do that
very proud to represent my dad but this
time round you know
being a biracial actress biracial person
i have two cultures that i can tap into
and
for queen charlotte she's very very much
based on my mother and that side of my
heritage so yeah i mean i was brought up
being traipsed around manor houses in
this country and afternoon tea and you
know all of that stuff scones and jams
and you know all of that you know so
to be able to celebrate her yeah um is a
real real joy and blessing
i mean i mentioned bridgestone i guess
what's weird is you're in the biggest
show in the world you're a global
superstar but you're presumably just
telling your fridge your opening yeah
it's just me and it's me and the four
walls and my cushions my exceedingly bad
cushions all my friends tell me
but has the postman have been impressed
to find reggie jean-page behind a door
um no because i don't go to the door
because i'm scared of the posty and
tabloids and bits that's the only bit
that's real about the club so you don't
know what's out there yeah you don't
know who's behind the door lockdown has
ended about three months ago
[Applause]
and this is why we don't think yeah
i just don't like an audience
of romantic gestures
you
i mean you were obviously very young now
you you loved a boy yes and he lived in
cork was it yes he did live in cork um
i'm mortified because he's going to know
exactly who i'm talking about i was only
five please keep that in mind when i
continue this story i don't i was really
in love with him and i thought for some
reason the most romantic thing he i
could do was to send him some of my
teeth
you'll never look at me the same
um yeah i wish this was your first tea
some of my milk yes
i love you yeah wrote him a letter and
thought very romantic gesture very
eye-catching they'll never forget you if
you said that you're the cutest thing
how old was he
also five five
thirty seconds
i feel like he'd thought somebody
kidnapped you and it was a ransom note
please mommy help us save nicola
the tooth fairy i really couldn't tell
you it was just an intro i've mellowed
out since then really
here's another odd link i can't imagine
this will ever happen again we've got
two people on the show who've played
queen charlotte yeah
because you were in the madness
yes yes absolutely
fish shoes and wigs yeah remember the
features i know exactly gotten the
[__] fee
[Laughter]
and if we see helen again as there you
are now you look fabulous there very
good there's the fish fish is the lacy
fan you're weak
i feel like
netflix
have invested more in the wigs
is that truck built around your wig
nearly
is that car just for you as well yeah
yeah
that used to rock up every time i needed
to go to set
wow because i couldn't if i was in a car
i had to kneel down so i would be on the
floor like that
with this wig it was a car but in that i
was able to sit properly and what's in
it is it dense
um it's garages
mice and all sorts of things actually
we've got a picture of you getting ready
and it does break it doesn't it looks
like a man's living in it it looks like
it looks like you're walking him up
that's about four o'clock on a very very
heavy day
of filming because when you wear these
sorts of costumes often you have to get
dressed outside of your dressing room
because your dressing room is never
quite big enough i haven't incorporate
you know this enormous thing and when i
did the madness of king george we had
very low budget so they gave me this
little caravan because he was shooting
on a set and it i swear to god it was
one of those caravans that i think girls
might have used women might have used by
the side of the road you know at a truck
stop when they wanted to make a bit of
money you know that kind of feel about
it this is like
gymnos
[Applause]
it was like so manky and disgusting in
there and i was supposed to get dressed
as queen charles down there so i used to
i'll get dressed outside i'd get dressed
out in the open air because it wasn't
enough
[Applause]
the studio
i know it's just gone up in flames yeah
region he is so hot
the fire alarm's gone off
i'll take that
can we please keep that in the show so i
can have it in the showroom
i mean yeah reggie's used to this
he walks in the shots
he puts in the chops the fire alarm goes
this is why i don't do the voice
i knew i shouldn't have done it yeah
that's why it doesn't open the door
because it'll probably be the fire
brigade
uh i'll just ch i'll just ch i'll just
check with people who know are we all
safe in our beds oh apparently we're all
good now
hey when when we heard about we were
promised it was going to be like this
you know really raunchy sexy and i was
watching it though where is the sex but
my god once you pull the rip cord it's
it's non-stop
there's a
bit i mean even you must have been kind
of you know at the table reed you must
have been going
i haven't spoken for pages
well i got my mouth full half time
which i was consistent on because i
think that's important to see on tv as
well because yeah that is uncommon that
you see that kind of power dynamic in
rawchy scenes and that's part of the way
that we did want to modernize the show
so the duke does have his mouth full and
he's proud of it um but yes there was
there was a fair bit um to be done on
the show because you're really going for
it but you're going for it in kind of
beautiful locations
i mean like and occasionally very
uncomfortable locations well yeah those
library steps didn't look easy
didn't you have room monitors in the
stately homes well this is a problem
because the set as usual is more
valuable than any of the actors so if
you're in like you know a 200 year old
bed or a 400 year old four poster um it
has to have a reminder like you know
when people kind of bring very expensive
jewelry around they have to have a
bodyguard there's a bodyguard for the
room and so at all times you know you've
got this minimal set everyone gets very
quiet very respectful and you kind of
you de-robe and you hit the bed and then
there's also just like fran in the
corner who's just standing there just
kind of deciding whether or not to look
she's like i have to look i'm not
allowed to look i have to look
could you please go easy on the bed it's
very very hard it's not quite so
enthusiastic oh oh do you got one
that's the inner monologue that i
imagine
is going on in the corner of the room
yeah i'll stop them in a minute
presumably you had to have the awkward
kind of family conversation before yeah
a little bit um i mean we've got a
family whatsapp group so there's a
couple of you know flash and red light
emojis and the odd peach emoji um
certain people have threatened to rate
my peach um but we missed a couple of
family members and so people do enjoy
the fact that like a couple of cousins
missed the memo um and so they're
watching the show i got a very stern
message in my my instagram dms i'll do
enough just going i you there really
needs to be a cousin warming i had to
make so many tactical cups of tea and i
left the room and made my tactical cup
of tea and came back and you were still
going so you had to start doing pots of
tea you know you had to kind of kind of
keep building up the three-course meal a
tasting menu
absolutely you know awkward during sex
scenes um no not really not when they're
done right because they're right this is
we've talked a lot about our wonderful
intimacy coordinator yeah so it's
scripted just like a dramatic scene
except physically scripted so you know
where your hands are going to be you
know whose hand's going to be where at
what point how you react to that it's
literally just choreography at which
point it takes the embarrassment out of
what i suppose yeah it takes the
embarrassment it also takes the risk out
because also that you can it's like
choreographing a fight scene yeah you
can do damage if you're not careful with
your co-stars yeah did you look at that
when the screen froze of me on good
morning britain did you use that maybe
i thought that was your audition
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure i make that face a
couple of times to be fair
[Music]
you